Every year on November 11th, our nation pays respect to Veterans Day,...
...a day when we honor our military veterans and thank them for their service...
...with songs, ceremonies, and festive parades.
It's a proud day filled with meaning for everyone who has served:
the great grandfather at Iwo Jima,...
...low crawling in volcanic ash;...
...the uncle who overcame fear for his own life,...
...fighting an unseen enemy in the jungles of Vietnam;...
...the sister on the streets of Baghdad during civil affairs missions;...
...the friend scanning the valley below for the enemy...
...from a mountaintop in Afghanistan;...
...even higher still, the neighbor who patrols the skies.
Veterans Day is a time to hear the stories of combat and sacrifice...
...from those who served our country,...
...and each has a powerful story to tell.
We have another story to share with you.
It's also a story of honor, integrity, and sacrifice.
Thousands of civilian volunteers, some without any direct connection to the military,...
...are giving their time, effort, and resources in support of our veterans every day.
The World War II Memorial here in Washington, DC...
...is the center of the grassroots effort happening all across this country.
Volunteers for the Honor Flight Network want to make sure World War II veterans...
...get a chance to experience this monument built in their honor.